hey guys I'm back and I wanted to create
a complete video on this one topic
abdominal gas and bloating I have a lot
of different videos talking about the
different pieces of this but I wanted
one video with all the different parts
so it's just kind of covering this a lot
of people are getting abdominal pain gas
and bloating they don't know what it is
so there's several there's actually four
main things the first one is SIBO small
intestinal bacterial overgrowth this is
a situation where you have too much
bacteria in the wrong location most of
the bacteria in your gut should be in
the large intestine not the small so
when you have too much of the bacteria
in the small intestine and then you eat
you're getting a lot of gas because
these microbes are are not meant to be
in that environment and the type of gas
that you're getting is hydrogen gas and
also methane gas so it can produce
belching burping bloating things like
that the best thing to do for this is to
get a test it's called hydrogen methane
breath test it's not invasive it's not
that expensive I think it might be $180
it's a kit that you can get you may need
a doctor's prescription for it so check
with your doctor and I'll put some links
down below of certain companies that can
that will sell you the kit you just need
to fax in the doctor's order so you can
actually get the kit I'm not a hundred
percent sure if every single company
that sells the kit needs a doctor's
order but I'll put some links down below
and you can check it out well that will
quickly rule out if you have this
condition okay all right now you could
also have a situation in number two
where you have an imbalance in microbes
you have too many methanogens and those
are microbes they're ancient
microbe little bugs that make methane
gas okay and it creates belching and
flatulence
hydrogen gas nothing yes so this is kind
of
a mild version of SIBO okay so these
methanogens consume polysaccharides
which are starches the sugars and really
what you have is you have a situation
you have excessive fermentation okay so
these fibers and sugars are just
producing a lot of gas okay
next situation you have low stomach acid
which by the way can set you up for SIBO
and also this condition right here but
let's say for example you're consuming a
lot of protein you can still get
abdominal gas and bloating if you don't
have enough stomach to digest the
protein next situation is decreased bile
bile is produced by the liver it's
stored in the gallbladder and if you
don't have enough bile
you'll definitely get belching and
bloating and gas because you're not
going to be able to digest the fats and
if you do a lot of nuts or oils without
in a file everything just kind of sits
there and you'll get start getting back
up and pain on the right side of your
body okay so what do we do the most
important thing to do is to cut down the
carbs why because that's going to reduce
the stress and inflammation in your gut
it's gonna really really help you you
also want to reduce fiber you may even
want to cut fiber out completely and I'm
talking about vegetable fiber for about
a month so you can let your system reset
why because if you have this especially
in the microbes or in the small
intestine they're gonna eat the fiber
and create more gas the problem is you
have excessive microbes in the wrong
place so you don't want to feed feed
them and keep them there we want them to
go away the other thing to do is in a
minute fasting for sure so we can
actually give the system a chance to
kind of clear out between the meals
vitally important now some people don't
need to cut out all the fiber they just
need to consume more cooked vegetables
and smaller amounts of them okay number
two add betaine hydrochloride very very
important betaine hydrochloride is a
natural thing to help increase your
hydrochloric acid realize that you need
a good amount of this before each meal
maybe even four to five to six or more
tablets before you eat to see a good
change in your digestion and it takes a
longer period of time it could take
months
to reestablish this acid in stomach a
lot of people have low stomach acid
especially if you have the history of
taking any acids or antibiotics or low
salt diet next thing is to avoid dairy a
lot of people have sensitivities to
lactose or allergies to casein which is
the protein in dairy and that can create
abdominal gas and bloating for sure and
last thing is to add bile salts if you
don't have enough file and how would you
know if you don't have enough bile
it's usually gonna cause pain on the
right shoulder or this area right
through it here or underneath the right
ribcage if you add purified bile salts
right after the meal that will reduce
the bloating and take the betaine how to
chloride before the meal there wouldn't
hurt to take both of these one before
the meal and one after the meal to
maximize your digestion so I just wanted
to kind of cover all the different
points so if you have intestinal gas I
think this will be helpful to overcoming
it thanks for watching if you're liking
this content please subscribe now and I
will actually keep you updated on future
videos